hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world
bringing drugs they're bringing crime
they're rapists and some I assume are
good people fact or fiction is the 2016
presidential campaign drifting into the
realms of unreality Plus picking up the
pieces after Black Friday and this our
Father in Heaven and I be your name
so can we really take this presidential
campaign seriously there have been some
surreal episodes than ever before could
this merely be the screenplay of the
political movie or are the real messages
getting through in just a moment we'll
speak to the author and executive
producer of house of cards Michael Dobbs
but as usual the Democrat commentator
Geoffrey Robinson is standing by a New
York and conservative commentator
Armstrong Williams is in Washington
Jeffrey this is at one heck of a
screenplay if somebody wrote it
absolutely I mean you can't invent this
stuff and when you when you think of it
in terms of house of cards I mean I have
we watched both series both the British
and the American and it's wonderful and
kudos to Michael Dobson for having come
up with us but I do have one criticism
Frank Underwood who is the American
political of character is such a
horrible dishonest deceitful conniving
lying cheating miserable son of a [ __ ]
surely he should have been a Republican
armstrong's you know I could have bet
that Geoffrey would make that accusation
have you caught the series everyone has
caught the series it's a fantastic
series there's so much realism as you
almost think you're watching not a
reality show but something has really
happening amenity political capitals
around the world and it is you're right
it is really a strange election season
how Donald Trump declaring this week
that he'd sold thousands and thousands
of Muslims cheering after nine eleven
and it was not even footage from the
United States it was something that
happened outside of the united states
and even when the media tells him that
he's factually incorrect he doubles down
I mean he just creates the facts and
whatever he wants to do his his his
audience doesn't seem to care and the
media seems to just just give throw
their hands up in the air and don't make
him as accountable as they do other
candidates that's running for the same
office let's bring in Michael dog shall
we Lord Dobbs a british conservative
politician and a best-selling author
best known of course for house of cards
Michael let's compare and contrast the
two systems could we and particularly
the amount of money involved this
presidential season they're talking of a
candidate needing something of the order
of two billion dollars to win the White
House isn't that bonkers it does seem
very strange particularly from a British
perspective but i suppose that is one of
the key differences between the systems
because that the British system is
becoming more presidential we pay much
more attention to who is prime minister
and leader of this party or lead with
that party then perhaps were used
through twenty thirty years ago but the
essential difference is the is it's the
money that's involved and which means
the different ways that you campaign you
you're way ahead of us on social media
for instance we just started catching up
on that and that was one of the reasons
I think for the Conservatives surprise
victory in the election here in May but
also you know America has the power you
know I'm very proud to be British and a
British politician but at the end of the
day it's an the American president who's
the leader of the Western world and
that's why it's so important to us all
when you had to adapt your story-telling
for the American environment was that
really tough was it very different Oh
politics ambition beastliness wickedness
great virtue they are really very very
universal eternal properties I think it
all really started for me when I as a
kid I was forced to read William
Shakespeare's Julius Caesar you know the
most powerful man in the world hacked to
death on the steps of his own capital by
his closest colleagues I mean and
politics has been the same ever since
really but you know what we have had to
make changes of course partly because
the American version is even more
ambitious than the british version was
and it's we're now 25 years later so
social media mobile technology 24 7 news
coverage plays a hugely important part
has changed the nature of politics but
the but what matters deep down to the
personalities and those personalities
their ambitions their faults and their
wickedness is easy turn
but I do have to emphasize that the
house of cards is a drama it is not a
documentary I spend most of my life
ninety percent of my life in politics
doing very dull ordinary things but at
the end of the day and they did it's the
dark places that you go to which really
tell you which really tell you what a
man or woman is capable of well let's
bring in Jeffrey and Armstrong at this
point Jeffrey the point is though that
anybody who really wants to go through
the pain becoming a candidate and maybe
winning the presidency they have to be
seriously ambitious don't they well
seriously ambitious and slightly crazy I
mean back in the in the days when lee
iacocca was chairman of Chrysler
Corporation and he wrote a best-selling
book that was on the on the New York
Times list for I don't know two years or
something somebody went to them and said
mr. Iacocca is this your bid for the
presidency is this the start of your
campaign and he said who would want to
be President first of all I have to take
a ninety percent salary cut second of
all what's the president got that I
don't have a plane I have a plane but
what I have the president doesn't have
is if I want to go out to dinner with my
wife I can just go I don't have to ask
anybody's permission I can do anything I
want and the type of person who would
run for the presidency is probably by
that regard most of all not qualified to
be President it's a very very strange
job that only certain people would want
I'm strong just on the structure of the
way the American system works the fact
that anybody literally anybody can get a
nomination to become president they
don't even have to be a leader or a
leading figure in their own party isn't
that a bit odd isn't that a weakness of
your system well you know I don't know
that's exactly accurate this is not the
first time that Donald Trump has toyed
with the idea of running with for
president is certainly the only true
outsider in this election season is
really not the ben Carson but most of
these people have extraordinary
backgrounds they're very accomplished in
their field where there's pediatric
neurosurgery whether it's an
entrepreneur and even as politicians
your governor
united states senator you've shown that
you can search people you've shown that
you could be a change agent for good
what happens though even if we look at
our past and our past leaders even from
john f kennedy to dwight david
eisenhower and fast-forward to reagan
encarta up until within the last 15 to
20 years you never had so much of a
focus on someone's background of their
personal lives on some issues that are
really non-substantive and you never had
this proliferation of media blockers in
social media where you just continue to
go in and so is background and talk
about their personal lives I mean and
much of a change with our former
President Bill Clinton and Monica
Lewinsky and so so much has changed and
we begin to believe that these people
are not substantive that their reality
figures but listen Donald trumpets are
really accomplished individual about how
Donald Trump operates in the political
sphere is a different ball game but
listen this is what the media created it
created what you have to make a lot of
money you have to spend a lot of money
and they create celebrities they don't
really create leaders anymore they want
to create people who can leave with
headlines and sellout debates and sell
our audience and get them ratings it's
really not the substance of the audience
and well at that point let me put that
to Michael tops isn't that the bonkers
part of the American system if you put
into one of your story lines that a
successful hôtelière wants to have a
stab the leadership wouldn't your
colleagues in the production team have
just laughed you out of the room I I
keep saying that actually writing
political fiction is very easy because
what you do is you take political
reality and then you water it down and
you have to make it credible because in
fiction people are required to act
rationally reasonably sanely and in
their own best interests and then you
pick up your newspaper or turn on the
television and you see what real
politicians so frequently get up to I
mean it's it's an extraordinary it's an
extraordinary system politics yeah I may
tell you that here we say that politics
is the world's second oldest profession
and takes most of its rules from the
first oldest profession but I I have to
say that in some ways I think that
politics probably doesn't have any rules
at all any
the rules are all going Jeffrey
literally anything goes well yes since
citizens united literally anything goes
mean the worst Supreme Court decision in
the history of the Supreme Court I will
say that when you go back to the Kennedy
election Kennedy Nixon it did get
personal and that was really the first
time they questioned the fact that a
Catholic could be president without
revealing national secrets to the Pope
that was one of the serious arguments
against John Kennedy it's crazy when you
look at what what has happened since and
i'm jon is right since the Monica
Lewinsky scandal when presidents kind of
stepped down a little bit from their
high altar and started looking very
human and very vulnerable we now we
elect people by television it's it's all
that and that's where the money going I
don't think this is going to be a two
billion dollar election but it's
certainly going to be a 1 billion dollar
election and one sort of television
cameras come in for a close-up you see
the candidate warts and all a proof ben
Carson who is disintegrating as we speak
as a viable candidate which he never was
Michael we should let you in on the is
no no secret of court but in the the
jousting between Jeffrey and Armstrong
in this jeffrey doesn't think much of
dr. ben Carson and Armstrong is an
associate of his so these two often
discuss the merits of this particular
candidate but let's widen it out a
little bit shall we and let's maybe
focus on the Democratic side of things
Michael haven't asked you who do you
think from the Democratic lineup for
2016 is going to succeed well in some
ways I feel as if the election campaign
really hasn't started yet it really
hasn't got to grips with it and one of
the worrying things that worries me
about where politics is going not just
in the States but actually all over the
West right now a time and time again
electorate's appear to be looking away
from established figures and established
parties away from experience and you see
that throughout Europe almost every
government that's come up for
re-election over the last six seven
eight years has been thrown out with one
or two possible exceptions and what
you're seeing with you know perhaps
Donald Trump and Ben Carson in the
States it people going
those without experience perhaps
precisely because they don't have that
experience not tired with that the
problems of failure but that really
worries me because where else what other
profession would you have where you say
I'm going to take the candidate with the
least experience well that's the lesson
on the job level Michael isn't it that's
the body part politics fault if the
present system the current system the
system up to 2015 has been so flawed or
people have become disillusioned with it
maybe this is why the outside of
candidates do so well that we're still
struggling to understand quite why this
should be so so universal and you ask
which of the Democratic candidates
prefer were on the basis of what i just
said one would actually possibly suggest
a Hillary Clinton because she certainly
has the experience but do people believe
that she is the that the person to
really deal with the problems of the
future when actually she appears to have
had quite a few problems dealing with
the problems of the past so to speak I
mean that that's really but the one
thing that you can rely on with Hillary
Clinton is she knows who she's talking
to and what she's talking about whether
she comes to the right judgment however
is something else and Armstrong one
thing every candidate needs if we take
the house of cards model is a ruthless
spouse so how many of the Lady Macbeth
figure I think she is probably but
anyway in terms of Robin Wright's
character that is how many of the
Republican candidates can boast a spouse
who's up to the job I think all over
bolster I think one of the things that
don't get much attention for now in this
presidential run are the spouses and
their backgrounds and their
accomplishments and especially for
spouses who have been associated with
politicians who continue to run for
officers and raise money they certainly
must have steely character know exactly
what they're dealing with and if you're
dealing with a spouse of a pediatric
neurosurgeon are a billionaire like
Donald Trump you're no slouch potatoes
I'm you've had to have some background
just to deal with with those men and
what they represent on the world stage
and so listen I would never end estimate
sometime it's the
woman who's the most ruthless of them
all and she gets the lease of attention
and she just trust a man out front
because they're more ambitious than a
man and want them like but Hillary
Clinton was once when former President
Bill Clinton she was the anchor behind
him no one will ever forget that 60
minutes interview when it they thought
it was all over for the Clintons and she
stepped up to the plate and showed her
steely backbone so I think they're more
women like her that we give credit for
can I just ask Michael about one other
thing about political numbers here
you're a member of the House of Lords
Michael the Americans I think arguably
may have a little better system for a
second house in a country with seven
times the population we've got they've
got a hundred elected representatives
popped in there for six years we've got
eight hundred and twenty-one and a lot
of them are there forever that's bonkers
isn't it no not a single one of them has
been elected in the House of Lords this
is the magic of the system and what
really matters is the effectiveness and
it seems to me that what you've got in
Washington right now are two elected
chambers and an elected president who
have clunked together and are getting
nothing done they can't agree with
anything and so you've got a state of
semi paralysis which is perhaps one of
the reasons why Frank Underwood a
ruthless wicked unpleasant politician
but my goodness me he gets things done
and I think that's what the Americans
are really desiring at the moment
somebody who could actually get
something done at this end yeah we're
unelected in the House of Lords but our
job is actually to to smooth we don't
always manage it successfully but it's
too smooth and oil the wheels of
government not to stop them turning so
if two very different systems with two
very different outcomes Jeffrey now
Michael Michael who spent a lot of time
in the united states and was partially
educated in the united states will know
why we've dumped your tea in the harbor
and why we completely rejected a
parliamentary system and why the system
of checks and balances between the
executive the legislature and the
judiciary was put into place the best
parliamentary government is usually a
minority government because then things
don't get done and i think the people
don't want stuff done I mean that's the
whole the whole Republican thing is we
hate government we don't want government
to do anything we
want the states to do it all weekend
politics is local no no we rejected the
parliamentary system and the Senate
works very well for certain things and
the Senate's job is well defined by the
Constitution the house job is well
defined and so is the presidency but I
may I ask Michael one question because
as a fellow author I'm fascinated to
know he originally wrote the novel or
Michael you originally wrote the novel
with a British character and when you
write a novel spend a year or two or
three doing that you have the British
character in your mind you see him you
know how he moves you know how he talks
you know everything about him what was
it like to suddenly see your British
character with whom you spent all those
years turned into an American character
over whom you had much less control how
did you accept that well can I can I
tell you a little secret little story
when the phone rang and the phone rang
mr. the hi Mike not nobody ever calls me
night but I like oh you know we want to
do your American version of of this and
um we've got Kevin Spacey and David
Fincher on board what do you think and I
said this has got to be a trick question
Fincher Spacey and I'm supposed to have
to think about this I thought for a 3
nanoseconds and said look whatever they
do it is going to be touched with a bit
of class and even if I have no control
over it whatsoever I know that they will
take my baby and they will grow it up
into a wonderful new human being and
creature and vehicle and that's what
they've done and it is still on the move
I mean but again the essence of the
story goes back at least 2,000 years and
you could probably have based it in in
ancient Egypt as well so for me it's a
matter of great excitement to see how
this thing is developing it's like
watching your child grow up good for you
good for you and cashing the check yeah
that's serious there is that too that
helps my family grow up I'm sorry is
there any part of Frank Underwood you
admire uh you know what there's always
some social redeeming value you may not
think that he is a caring person but on
some level he really cares about the
country and he feels this is what he has
to do
become to protect the country and it
could protect the interests of those
that he feels he cares about most and he
does it in a ruthless way and I think he
reminds all of us what we could possibly
become and like you said earlier he
generates results I just hope that
people don't think you have to take his
path in terms of lacking character to
manufacture and get things done and get
the job done but I don't think I'm Frank
Underwood it's too far apart for many
people and Elektra officer around the
world today I think he's a
representative of what people not just
surely have become but what they've
always been Michael don't give too much
away because I'm still working through
season three but you're already filming
season for right now in 2015 so
presumably that a is in election year
then what happens well I think we will
have to see we will sit down and we will
get the as wonderful creative brains
together and see what we think the how
the runes will cast because of course it
is a challenging year next year because
if the drama is to really strike a chord
as it's done then it has to have some
semblance to reality and the reality as
we know in a presidential election year
will be changing and changing fast so
it'll be a huge challenge but if we get
it right our it'll be wonderful and so
far I think and believe that we have got
it right so I'm full of confidence and
full of optimism that whoever wins the
the presidential election next year that
Frank Underwood will be up there Lord
Dobbs Mike thank you both very much
thank you
now reminder you can catch up with the
Sky News debate on Apple TV Roku and
catch up and of course at Sky News calm
/ us yes it's the Thanksgiving weekend
time for festivities fun food and films
how do you celebrate let's ask our
guests Jeffrey and Armstrong armstrong
with the thanksgiving what does it mean
in your home well thanksgiving for us is
the biggest holiday of the year because
you know i find myself in south carolina
with the entire family uh it's a it's a
time of being neighborly it's a time of
remembrance it's a it's a time of its
just a time of reflection and so more
than any other holiday during the years
when all the family is together to
celebrate all the good things that have
happened not only an allies but but in
this country though we face these crisis
is like terrorism and parents with our
brothers and sisters in Europe and
around the world we are set definitely
thankful for the things that sometimes
we forget to be thankful for and
Geoffrey this is something that really
does unite the United States of America
isn't it absolutely it's a time for
family and and for those who can't get
to family when my daughter was at
University here in New York she'd always
say oh by the way can this one or that
one come for thanksgiving and the
automatic answer is yes of course
because people need to go someplace for
thanksgiving it's a very important thing
interestingly enough i've always been
fascinated with the real story of
thanksgiving which by the way is not an
American holiday it actually was started
by the British it's a great story in 17
I think it was seventeen eighty nine or
so George Washington proclaimed a
national holiday called Thanksgiving not
to celebrate the pilgrims landing at
Plymouth Rock in 1621 but instead to
celebrate the newly formed Constitution
of the United States it wasn't it so 74
years later that Abraham Lincoln said oh
no let's change it and we'll have
Thanksgiving and celebrate the pilgrim
story which is the one that all
schoolchildren an American know about
Massasoit and the Indians and the lunch
under the trees and turkey and popcorn
the Indians gave
popcorn but none of that's actually true
two years before that in 1619 there was
a service of thanksgiving by a small
British colony in Berkeley plantation
which was somewhere near at Culver City
Virginia and they actually called it a
celebration of thanksgiving and had a
meal afterwards so we owe the
celebration of thanksgiving not to the
pilgrims but to the british in their
colony of berkeley plantation well I'm
glad that British did all the right
things Geoffrey I just want we often
share things and get you guys to talk
from an American perspective about
events in your country and around the
world I'm going to share something now
that's happened in our countries kind of
interesting ahead of the Star Wars films
a cinema chain has decided it's not
going to run an advert which the Church
of England created the advert was simply
various regular people doing a montage
of the Lord's Prayer here's an example
our Father in heaven Hallowed be your
name
I can come come and so it goes on
throughout the prayer now the idea i
think was just to invite people who may
or may not be a people of faith to have
a think about these things at this
particular time of year Jeffrey and
Armstrong Armstrong lets you have a
thought the cinema chain advertising
people have said they're not going to
run it because some people might be
offended what does an American think of
that you know you a lot of marketplace
to decide that we've had issues with the
passion of christ we've had issuers
would make it with nor and the art and
when the other rows but when they feel
as though that what the production in
hollywood was putting out was not a
depiction of what no rules really about
it did really do well at the box office
that's a business decision that's not
something that the government anybody
should get in let the box office aside
what do people want to attend it or not
or whether people want to protest it
Jeffrey what do you make of this i I
don't understand it at all I mean I i
think that the decision is completely
bonkers the Lord's Prayer of all of the
prayers is probably the most neutral
religiously neutral doesn't mention
Christ doesn't mention Israel doesn't
mention any of the the various factions
who would recite it that the 23rd psalm
I just don't get it how can you how can
you be offended by that but it's up to
the market to decide I'm strong that
you'll know she'll take on this you know
it's up to the market decide we we have
issues like this similar in the United
States and the people always come out on
top when it is put their dollars in
their voice and teach Hollywood any
other institution a lesson about where
our values truly lie and if that was an
issue in the United States the the
people would win it hands down and the
Lord's Prayer will be in those cinemas
across the country but let the market
decide well let talking of markets let's
go from God to Mammon shall we Black
Friday Cyber Monday are you getting the
credit card out this weekend Armstrong I
like helping the economy I think these
stores people like ourselves after spend
money with retailers and others so I see
it as supporting my brother's especially
as the entrepreneur anything I can do to
support them I go to the stores to show
support not necessarily but it goes but
they want in the same
it is a strange phenomenon though Jeff
or isn't it it really has taken off and
now you've it's another export that you
guys have sent over here should stalk
stores and retail chains are going mad
for this yeah we've got to support the
economy some in some way by the way the
sirens of you hear them welcome to New
York we're waiting for a drive-by
shooting any minute now the the economy
needs a boost this is a great way to do
it and I know that my wife and I have
sat down we said look black friday cyber
monday we may want to make a major
purchase and decided the only thing we
really need is printer ink it is that
effect do you get that discounted by
somebody on on Black Friday this is
America get everything discount and
delivered for free okeydoke and if
there's one thing on your shopping list
Armstrong what might it be my shopping
list you know I actually like shopping
for others or technology and things
that's going to increase my especially
my nieces and nephews education but you
know what look I just like shopping
fathers and you never know until you
walk in the store it's the holidays you
walk in something this store you see
something that somebody you really care
about what life and you just purchase it
you have no idea what you're going to
purchase so it's best be open that's
when you get your best buys instead of
going in there with some preconceived
notion about like you want to purchase
okay well listen let me wish you both a
very happy holiday weekend and we'll see
you in a week's time on this show that's
it for this edition of the debate you
can continue watching sky news on apple
TV on roku and catch up and of course at
Sky News calm until next time goodbye